lawmakers in carson city have just hours
left until the end of the legislative
session
that means they may not meet again until
2023
eight news now is your only local
station on the ground at the capitol
that's where we find the itunes david
charns
who is live there with everything that's
happening right now david
well christian you could say they always
leave the big stuff for last right and
that is what's happening right now but
there was some stuff
that has already gone past today we saw
nevada moving from a caucus state to a
primary state that is now going to the
governor
we also saw decriminalization of getting
a traffic ticket so first i want to
talk about those primaries if the
governor signs this nevada would hold
primaries
to choose party candidates for president
every february instead of having those
caucuses possibly
as the nation's first primary there's
been a push to do this for a while now
especially after
chaos and long lines we saw back in 2020
this proposal passed with both support
from
democrats and republicans now also
moving forward there will no longer be
jail time tied to
paying a traffic fine or not showing up
for court
if you get a ticket instead a new
collection system is going to be set up
to deal with that
this also had widespread support in both
the assembly and the senate
but for that solution to addressing
traffic issues to be solved in the
criminal justice system
unfortunately usually ends up in just
additional jail time
we need to keep in mind there's some
very small counties with very limited
budgets and
for them to be able to implement this is
going to be very very difficult
now also moving forward today more state
agencies other than
the dmv will be able to auto register
voters that had widespread democratic
support the secretary of state also will
start a
top-down voter registration system
something that both parties wanted here
in terms of
election security and what we saw after
the election back in november in terms
of cross
checking people's registration from
county to county
we're still waiting though on what
happens with that mining tax it did pass
in the assembly just about 15 minutes
ago
we're waiting for it to go over to the
senate also that public health option
when it comes to health insurance
we'll keep you posted through the night
it's going to be a long one but they
have to end
by midnight tonight we're live in carson
city i'm david charns a news now
david charns joining us live tonight
from carson city thank you so much david